[Music]
all right up next we have heidi in
boston hey heidi welcome to the show
hi rachel and george thank you for
taking my call sure how can we help
um so listen my husband and i we want
the american dream to buy a house but we
don't want to be upside down on the
house years from now
my husband and i have saved
28
of a down payment on the house and we
have no debt
however we're very frustrated with the
way the market is uh the bidding wars
the rat race of it all having to bid
like
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
for a house that has issues and we're
just not willing to do that we're not
willing to
do this huge investment the biggest
investment of our lives
and
come out potentially um
upside down later down the road
i think that
we really need help and advice on
what to do should we settle
i mean
a lot of people have been telling us
oh why are you having all that money on
for your down payment nobody cares about
that the pmi isn't that much and we're
holding to our guns here but
they have those in boston very
frustrated
i'm from the boston area so i i feel you
on that the real estate debacle there
and it's happening all over the country
but especially in a big city like boston
east coast west coast and so what kind
of house are you looking at what's the
price point
um
my husband and i we bring in
we'll bring in 369 this year before
taxes
um
we're looking we were pre-approved for
about 8.50 but we're looking for more of
a 650
area we don't want to be on the very top
of our budget we want to be comfortable
i think that we have the right idea it's
it's just we don't we kind of feel like
we're forced into a really bad situation
and
i don't want to use the term unfair
because i know life isn't fair
but my husband and i work hard and
we don't
we want to be able to not be stuck in
our lives we want to have kids someday
we we just don't know what to do frankly
yes and i would say heidi any time you
feel forced in a financial situation you
could make a really bad decision so so
anytime there's options that would be my
thing options options options now
are you going to pay more than you did
24 months ago yeah you are because of
the yeah the housing market we all know
it's just it's insane right now um but
could you guys get to a number that you
feel comfortable with and to say you
know regardless of market this is the
amount of money we want to spend and
because of that in this market this is
the house we're going to get do we feel
good about that
and if the answer is no to any of those
then just
you can pause heidi you got there's no
one forcing you guys to buy a home right
now you really i know you're frustrated
and you want a home and all of that i
get that but even if you just have the
breaks for just say i mean another nine
months like i wonder what fall of 2022
is gonna be like uh you guys will have
more money saved up you can see if the
market at all corrects itself
but give yourself some time and do not
feel forced into a situation because
what what is the urgency for you guys of
buying a home is it just that you're
just you don't want to rent anymore and
you're like oh we just want we just want
a home
well we've been married three years and
we live in an apartment right now in
malden and the rent it keeps on
increasing every year we've been in the
same apartment first six years now when
the
rent's going to increase again
the amount of that we're paying now
would be is higher
than what our expected mortgage
per month including like property taxes
and stuff like that would be
and plus we want to start a family and
the area that we live in right now isn't
really um
ideal for that
well heidi here's what i would do like
rachel's saying i'm going to use this
time to buy me some patience and save up
even more and that's what we did when we
were we were building at our home and
every time there was a delay i just went
sweet one more month to save up for that
down payment and we got a huge down
payment on that house because of that
and so that may else also help you
upgrade in-house and over time if you're
working with a great real estate agent
and let me tell you if you don't have
one you can jump onto
ramseysolutions.com
and find a ramsey trusted elp doors
local provider in the boston area who's
rockstar and they can help you navigate
this weird time so that you don't get
screwed so that you're not paying a
hundred thousand over asking to get into
a house so i'm gonna do it when the time
is right but that doesn't mean you can't
be searching and trying and i know it's
frustrating and it can be disheartening
but this is just the market we're in and
if you want a house right now you got to
play the game but use this time to keep
saving up maybe you guys could put 40 50
down on this house that could be
incredible yeah absolutely and i think
that's what's hard as when you feel
forced again in a situation
that can be dangerous and and people do
that i know this isn't your case
specifically honey but even
people they find the perfect house and
they this is the only house this is the
only house where they find the car this
is the only car it's the only car i'm
gonna overpay and i'm you know you make
you know you make bad decisions when
it's this very very tunnel vision and so
to be able to say that yes we want a
house we want a house here in the next
18 months so now in 18 months we'll be
saving and we're going to be looking for
a home and give yourself that patience
height but you guys are doing awesome
you make great money you got a great
down payment you're gonna be great